[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشر المفصله من العربيه انا
ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه مشاهدينا
واوكرانيا تدرس احتماليه اخلاء العاصمه
مؤتمر وشرم الشيخ يناقشه تعويض الدول
المتضرره من تغير المناخ وتحذيرات من
انبعاثات الكربون
النظام الايراني يلجا للرصاص الحي ضد
المحتجين واشتباكات بمريون بعد مقتل فتاه
على يد الامن
قبيل انطلاق انتخابات التجديد النصفي
بايدا يعتبرها لحظه فارقه للديمقراطيه
وترامب يحشد لدعم حزبه
اذا مشاهدينا دعونا نبدا هذه النشره من
اخر التطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا فمع
تواصل استهداف روسيا لمنشات الطاقه
باوكرانيا بدا المسؤولون في العاصمه
بالتخطيط الاحتمال غير مسبوق هو اخلاء
سكان المدينه بالكامل في حال حدوث انقطاع
كلي للتيار الكهربائي وفقا لصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز فقد تعرضت 40% من البنا التحتيه
للطاقه في اوكرانيا للدمار نتيجه القذف
الروسيه
واذا استمرت روسيا في مثل هذه الهجمات فمن
الممكن ان تفقدك يا ابن النظام الكهرباء
وبالكامل طبعا في هذا السياق افاده مدير
الامن في حكومه بلديتك افاد انه يتلقى
انذارا بان شبكه على شكل انهيار قبل حدود
ذلك باثنتي 10 ساعه على الاقل مضيفا ان
الاخلاق في هذا الحال سيكون ملزما بسبب
توقف الخدمات التي تعتمد على الكهرباء
بالمدينه مثل الماء ونتحدث ايضا عن الصرف
الصحيه
لكن لنكن صادقين اعدائنا يبذلون قصار
جهدهم لكي تكون المدينه من دون تدفئه
وكهرباء وامدادات المياه وبشكل عام يريدون
منا جميعا نموت هذه هي مهمتهم يعتمد هذا
على مدى قدرتنا على الصمود وعلى مدى
استعدادنا لسنروهات مختلفه يعتمد مستقبل
بلدنا ومستقبل كل مواطن على مستوى
الاستعداد لذا يجب ان نكون مستعدين
طبعا هذا بالنسبه للتوقعات في ما يتعلق
بانقطاع الكهرباء في كيف اما في خرسون فقد
افاد مسؤولون روس من قطاع الكهرباء عن تلك
المدينه اي خرسون وبالكامل وذلك بعد
الاعلان عن تضرر رصدقاك بضربات اوكرانيه
بصواريخ هيمارس وذكرت الوكاله نقلا عن
مسؤوليه طوارئ ان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه
اسقطت خمسه صواريخ منها فيما اصاب السادس
السد والذي يعمل بالطاقه الكهرومائيه
روسيا حذرت في وقت سابق من خطر استهداف
هذا السد حيث سيؤدي الى ارتفاع منسوب
المياه واغراق الاراضي المحيطه
وفي غضون ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه عن مقتل شخص جراء القصف الروسي
الاخير لشركه تجاريه بمدينه زبوريجيه فيما
اظهر محطات مصوره جهود فرق الاطفاء لاخماد
الحرائق تسبب بها هذا القصف دعنا نتابعه
[موسيقى]
المزيد من التفاصيل معنا من اكياس مراسل
العربيه هنسفيان اهلا بك هاني قبل ان ابدا
بالتطورات الميدانيه اصداء مثل هذه
التصريحات المتعلقه باخلاقك بالقطاع
الكهرباء ربما بشكل كامل
هناك كانت الاسابيع الماضيه
انقطاع في التيارات الكهربائيه كان هناك
قلق ايضا وخوف من قبل المواطنين هنا في
العاصمه كيف من
مواصلاته وايضا استمرار عمليه انقطاع
الكهرباء الحكومه الاوكرانيه صرحت بان
هناك سوف يكون جدوله في ظل همم استمرار
التهديدات الروسيه وفي ظل ايضا همم
استهدافها لبعض محطات الطاقه المياه وكذلك
الكهرباء سوف يكون هناك جدول على الاحياء
ولكن دعيني ايضا ان نرعي ونطلع الساده
المشاهدين الان الحياه هنا في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه هي اجواء ضبابيه وكذلك ممطره
وايضا حركه المركبات تسير همم بسهوله ويسر
الوقود متوفر بشكل كامل همم الغذائيه في
همم محلات التجاريه متوفره بشكل كبير
المواطنين في همم خاصه مع اجازه نهايه
الاسبوع ليوم هي ااا
يخرجون الى الاماكن همم السياحيه داخل كيف
وكذلك المتنزهات لكن المشكله الان هي في
محطات الطاقه الكهربائيه المتضرره وكذلك
المازوت الذي يعاني او تعاني منها الحكومه
الاوكرانيه هذا بطبيعه الحال همم هو يسبب
قلق وهاجس بالنسبه للمواطنين ولكن عندما
نسال هؤلاء المواطنين كيف سوف تكون وكيف
سوف يقضون حياتهم في همم فتره همم الشتاء
وموسم الشتاء خاصه ان هناك قرابه او خلال
الشهر القادم سوف يحل عليهم الشتاء رغم
البروده همم شديده الان في هذه الفتره تصل
درجه الحراره الى درجتين مئويه هذا ما
يسبب القلق بالنسبه لهم لا يعلمون كيف سوف
تكون المرحله المقبله بالنسبه لهم عمده
كيف يتحدث عن استعدادات لما هو قادم طبيعه
الاستعدادات او ليس هناك اي شيء حتى الان
وبالمقابل هناك حديث عن عمليه اخلاء هل في
قبول من الشارع لاخلاء المدينه لاخلاء
العاصمه
نعم ليس هناك قبول من قبل الشارع
والمواطنين هنا في لا ننسى ايضا ان
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ما زالت تقوم باستمرار
دعمها للحكومه الاوكرانيه رئيسه مفوضيه
الاوروبيه في حديث سابق لها قالت ان
اوكرانيه تحتاج شهريا ما لا يقل عن ثلاثه
مليار
الدولار كا يعانات وايضا دعم غير
الاعلانات العسكريه همم هناك ايضا من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي يقوم بدعم اوكرانيات في
الموارد والخدمات همم مساله مغادره على
مواطنين او اخلاهم او اجلائهم الى مناطق
غير كيف هي مرفوضه تماما لدى الشارع هنا
في العاصمه الاوكيه
شكرا جزيلا لك
افاده صحيفه واشنطوس بان الولايات المتحده
تشجع اوكرانيا ولكن سرا على التلميح
بالانفتاح على التفاوض مع روسيا بعد ان
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان موسكو
تصعد الحرب وليست رغبه بجديه في المشاركه
في محادثاته سلام
رسائل وسريه
ورغم ان واشنطن ترى ان موسكو ليست راغبه
باجراء محادثات سلام الا انها وبحسب
واشنطن بوست تشجع اوكرانيا سرا على التخلي
عن رفضهم العلني المشاركه في اي محادثات
سلام
لكن بين سطور الرسائل الهدف ليس الضغط على
اوكرانيا للجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات انما
محاوله محسوبه لضمان ان تحافظ كيف على دعم
دول اخرى تقرير الصحيفه كشف ايضا ان رفض
الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي اجراء محادثات مع نظيره
الروسي تسبب بقلق في اجزاء من اوروبا
وافريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه وهي الدول
التي تعاني التداعيات الاقتصاديه للحرب في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
من بيلاروسيا الى اسطنبول مفاوضات
الجانبين ظلت عالقه عند مطلب كل طرف لكن
ضم روسيا الاخير لاربعه اقاليم اوكرانيه
فجر قرارا واقعه زنسكي يقضي بعدم التفاوض
مع روسيا الا في حال سحبت كافه قواتها
رفض كل منزل نسكي وبوتن للحوار وتراجع
حماس بعض الدول الاوروبيه جعل المفاوضات
اكثر تعقيدا وصعوبه من اي وقت مضى خاصه مع
دخول الصراع الروسي الاخراني شهره الثامن
لكن على ما يبدو فان التقدم الاخراني
ميدانيا ربما شجع الاداره الامريكيه الى
دفعها للمفاوضات في ظل الازمات الاقتصاديه
التي يشهدها العالم
الدبلوماسيه سابق اهلا بكما وابدا معك سيد
مارس بقراءه لهذه التسريبات والمعلومات
والاشارات التي تاتي من الولايات المتحده
كيف تستقبل كيف وهل بالفعل تشعرون على
الاقل من خلال التصريحات ان مثل هذا الضغط
موجود فعلا السلام
نحن نجد في امريكا لمده تقريبا ثلاثه اشهر
من
الجرائد مختلفه هذا سبيل الله بانه موجود
وكلاء نفوذ روسيا داخل امريكا همم داخل
كمان الاتحاد الاوروبي روسيا تحتاجها الان
باي ثمن
روسيا وبعدين سوف يتم هذه
لتعزيز قواتها وبعدين سوف تهاجم مره ثانيه
مره ثانيه على اوكراني لان هذا
التبعات اذا ما حدثت هذه المفاوضات انا
فقط اريد ان ارى كيف تفكر اوكرانيا بمثل
هذه التصريحات التي تاتيكم من الولايات
المتحده هل تعتقد بالفعل انه هناك بالفعل
نوع من الضغوط الامريكيه على كيف او لا
غير موجوده مجرد ما مقالات مجرد تسريبات
مجرد قراءات خاطئه ربما
سوف تحصل على مساعدته جديده عسكريه همم من
امريكا يعني كم انا قلت هذه الناشره في
هذه جريده يعني عند همم عند الرؤوس
موجودين بالكلام نفوس داخل امريكا بصفه
عامه لا توجد
هناك تاثير او لا
تاثير موجود ولكن صغي يعني بصفه عامها قال
ان سلطه امريكيه وكما نجحته روبي تدركوا
بان من الضروري بان نتخلص مع نظام لان
بوتين هو يستخدم وهو يمتاز علمنا مواصل به
اسلحه نوويه بتجويد اوروبا الاخوان
مثل هذه الاشارات وهل بالفعل هناك نوع من
التغول اذا ما صح التعبير ولو المحدود
الروسي داخل الادارات الامريكيه
والاوروبيه وهو الذي يحاول ان يبعث بهذه
الرسائل
انا مستغرب
ان اا جريده واشنطن بوسه هذا احد وكلاء
امريكا
يومات هو الاخبار من جانب اداره
امريكيه مباشره
لاداره ديمقراطيه
ما الذي يعزز من هذه القناه لانه دائما ما
تخرج تصريحات وتسريبات وتقول في كثير من
الاحيان انها مجرد فقاعات او ربما نوع من
الكذب للحقيقه ما الذي يعزز من هذه
الفرضيه الان وهل التعويل على الانتخابات
بمعنى اخر همم النصفيه الامريكيه ام ماذا
بالاشاك كل هذا تسرب المعلومات بين
القوسين
الانتخابات
انتخابات الكونجرس امريكي ولذلك
حزب ديمقراطي
العام العالمي لاته ايده الفكره الرفض
الحبشي
الحكومه حتى في
بريطانيا
هزيمه كامله في حقل القتال في الميدان
وهذا كانت بعد همم
مضادات
اسطنبول
ان هناك كانت همم اتفاق نسبي والله بنروح
حول طرق الحاله السياسي ولكن الروشا كانت
مع الحاله شيء يعيش في البدايه الرفد اجا
مش منزل الرفض ايجي من رياضه الامريكيه
بلانكين ومن برج جونسون
في الولايات المتحده قادره على فرض الرفض
من قبل الاوكرانيين للارتفاع كيف لا
تستطيع ان تفرض الحوار والتفاوض لانه ضيفه
يقول بانه لا توجه الان بما معناه لكيف
لفرطه فوضات الا بعد الانسحاب وغيره من
الشروط الموجوده ودعني انتقل اليه الى
سيدمر للحديث عن الولايات المتحده
والانتخابات الى اي حد هناك تخوف بالفعل
حقيقه همم بنتائج الانتخابات لان هناك كما
نعلم دفع من البعض نحو وقف الحرب وقف
المساعدات اللي عم تحكي عنها بانها تعزز
من موقف الدعم امريكي لاوكرانيا باستكمال
همم العمليه العسكريه
من رئيس
نتيجه من الانتخابات هناك في كونجرس
امريكي يجعل كل حال سوف يكون دعم عسكري
كبير ودعم مالي كمان
روسيات نحن وانت طيب
نحن نشهد بان السلطه الاتحاد الاوروبيه
وهي تعبت من كل هذه ابتزازات الروسيه
باستخدام اصل انا وهي لتجميتك حاضر الضغط
هو طعبا من هذا القاعده اسمح لي البعض
ربما يقول بهذا الاطار انه الدول
الاوروبيه تتحرك بحسب هواء الولايات
المتحده ان تغير فستتغير وبالمقابل هناك
ضغوطات داخليه الان على الدول الاوروبيه
ومن هو رافض لاستكمال دعم اوكراني عسكريا
في ظل التطورات الاقتصاديه والضغوطات
جميل
ولكن بصفه عامه في اتحاد اوروبي على رغم
كل سوء بعض على هذه الازمه داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي نحن نعصر مين سامحني المساعده
والدعم همم مين الشعب الاوروبي تمام مساعد
انسانيه خيريه هي الضخمه من الاتحاد
عسكريه وخاصه
التي قدمت اليوكانيا
وكمان معروف يعني رئيس المانيا هو
بيان المانيا سوف تقدم مستعد في اعاده
البناء البنيه تحتيه كهربائيه
يومين عم نحكي عنهم حتى نعرف التوجهات
الامريكيه ومن هو قادر على التاثير اعود
الى ضيف فيتش لاف في سؤال الاخير يتعلق
بالتصريحات اللي امنتم فيها وبتسريبها
اعلاميا تقول انه هناك دفع للحوار طالما
بوتن على راس السلطه بمعنى اخر هل تعتقد
انه في نظره خارجيه انه ممكن ان يحدث غير
ذلك
لا هذا لا يلعب اي دور اولا ان بوتين
مستعد من بدايه من شهر 24 الشباك يلتقي مع
السلطه بكره
حل السياسه ولكن الشروط الذي قدمت روسيا
للسلطه اوكرانيه
في اسطنبول روسي
تؤيد المفاوضات ولكن تقترح الارضيه ارضيه
علاج سلمت لغروف لكليباتي ابريل
شكرا جزيلا لكم ومن كيف ولديمير شوما كوبا
دبلوماسيه سابق شكرا جزيلا لك
الى ولايه جورجيا الامريكيه الان اعلنت
النائبه في الحزب الجمهوري مارجرجرين انه
في حال فوز الجمهوريين في الانتخابات
النصفيه فلا يكون هناك تمويل اضافي
لاكرانيا
لكنهم يعطون الاهميه للحدود الاوكرانيه
فقط وليس حدود امريكا الجنوبيه تحت حكم
الجمهوريين لنذهب فيلسون اخر الى اوكرانيا
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
بتزامن مع مؤتمر شرم الشيخ للمناخ ناشطاني
يلسقان نفسهما بلوحتين في متحف برادو في
مدريد
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه نقبل من مصر
وابانا انطلاق اعمال مؤتمر الامم المتحده
للمناخ كوب 27 المنعقده اعمالها في مدينه
شرم الشيخ وافق المندوبون المشاركون في
المؤتمر على مناقشه مساله تعويض الدول
الفقيره الاكثر عرضه للتضرر من تغير
المناخ من قبل الدول الغنيه تجدر الاشاره
ان القمه تعقد على مدى 13 يوما بحضور ممثل
حوالي 200 دوله فيما يجتمع الرؤساء يومي
الاثنين والثلاثاء
ان الوقت قد حال للانتقال من المفاوضات
والتعهدات الى مرحله يحظى فيها التنفيذ
بالاولويه وفاه ذلك حتميه التعجيل بتنفيذ
ما ترادين عليه في الاتفاقيه الايطاليه
لتغير المناخ
وعززنا في اتفاق باريس وبرنامج العمل
الخاص به مع ضروره رفع مستوى الطموح لكل
الدول وفقا لقدراتها المتباينه
[موسيقى]
هذا هو بتزامل مع انطلاق فعاليات مؤتمر
المناخ في شرم الشيخ شهيده العاصمه
المصريه القاهره مبادرات توعويه متنوعه
تسعه لنشر ثقافه الحفاظ على مياه نهر
النيل من الملوثه
يتسلل هذا الشاب لالقاء القمامه على ضفاف
النهر مشهد يتكرر كثيرا والنتيجه اكوام من
القمامه يذهب بعضها الى اعماق النهر
مخلفات المواطنين تنضم لمخلفات المصانع
والمراكب والصرف الصحي تقارير تتحدث ان
الاعوام الماضيه شهدت زياده في معدلات
تلوث مياه نهر النيل ثلاثه اسباب رئيسيه
صرف صناعي صرف صحي صرف زراعي اي من
الثلاثه دول بيصل الى مياه نهر النيل
وترعه تتسبب في تلوث كبير في مياه النهر
هو لدول اسباب تلوث نهر النيل في الماضي
انما تم تقنينهم حاليا وتم ايقاف هذا
التلوث عدد من الوزارات المعنيه قامت
بالتنسيق مع شركات خاصه ومنظمات للمجتمع
المدني باطلاقه مبادره لتن النيل انا
حامله تنطلق بالمحافظتي القاهره والجيزه
وتهدف للوصول الى اسوان في الجنوب والهدف
هو ازاله المخلفات ونشر الوعي بين
المواطنين حول اهميه الحفاظ على نظافه
النيل النهارده الهلال الاحمر مشارك في
الحمله بقوه تطوعيه اا تبلغ 600 متطوع
متواجدين في 12 محافظه ايضا متواجدين بقوه
تطوعيه بتساعد نفسها في جمع المخلفات
لمياه النيل كجزء من دورنا في همم
المساعده في رفع الوعي همم اثار التغيرات
المناخيه
تتزامنه مع استعداد مصر لتنظيم قمه قاب 27
للمناخ دي حاجه احنا بيتهيالي مش لازم ان
احنا نبقى بنعملها بس قبل المؤتمرات
الشبيهه بكده دي المفروض انها تبقى همم
حاجات احنا بنعملها على طول
والبيئه مواطنونه يطالبون بيسني المزيد من
قوانين الرضاعه للمخالفين سواء كانوا
افرادا ام اصحاب المنشات المشكله ان هي
فعلا المشكله في صديقتي الناس يعني دلوقتي
كل واحد بيبقى معاه زباله بيقوم راميه في
النيل وربما يبقا تحدي الابرز فيما يتعلق
بملف تلوث مياه نهر النيل هو في القدره دي
في تغيير ثقافه المواطنين في التعامل
البيئي مع شريان الحياه لملايين المصريين
احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره
لوحتين زيتيتين مشهورتين للفنان الاسباني
فرانسيسكو دي غويا في متحف برادو في مدريد
ذلك في احد احدث الاحتجاجات التي تستهدف
الاعمال الفنيه في انحاء اوروبا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اليسا
[تصفيق]
المزيد معنا من شرم الشيخ مراسله العربيه
رنده ابو العزم اهلا بك رندا اين وصلت او
وصل هذا المؤتمر تفضلي
هو بدا بدا اليوم
من اليوم الى اليوم الثامن عشر من نوفمبر
اليوم كانت جلسه اجرائيه شاهدنا معا ااه
وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري يتسلم
رئاسه قمه المناخ الدوره السابعه والعشرون
وايضا يتحدث عن اهم التحديات ثعابين ميسون
ان من اهم التحديات تحدي التمويل فجوه
التمويل كبيره جدا كان هناك تعهدات بمئه
مليار دولار منذ قيمه كوبنهاجن عام 2009
ولم يتم يعني الوفاء حتى بهذا التعهد
والان هذا التعهد واقل بكثير من ما هو
مقلوب ايضا الانبعاثات الكربونيه في ظل
ازمه الطاقه التي تواجه العالم همم
الاحداث والسرعات الجيو السياسيه
وانعكاساتها على هذا المؤتمر كل هذه
التحديات بتفرض نفسها على هذا المؤتمر
ولكن هناك مطالبات بان يخرج هذا المؤتمر
وهذه القمه
باليات للتفعيل لان الخطر يحدق بالعالم
جميعا وليس بدوله بعينها همم ايضا الغا
يوم غد هو اليوم ال- همم الابرز في وصول
القاده والرؤساء هناك قمه مهمه جدا ال-
همم
المره الثانيه او الجلسه الثانيه النسخه
الثانيه من قمه الشرق الاوسط الاخضر
برعايه سمو ولي العهد الامير محمد عبد
العزيز محمد بن سلمان ستعقد غدا في
الرابعه والنصف مساءا حتى السادسه بحضور
عدد كبير من القاده عدد كبير من القاده
بالفعل سيشاركه في هديه
همم
البرازيلي هناك همم القاء الضوء بعض شيء
كونه سيكون الالتزام الدولي الاول بالنسبه
له بعد انتخابه وايضا البرازيل المهمه
بهذا الايطار لانها رئه العالم
نعم نعم يعني كما ذكرتي قمه الارض كانت في
البرازيل وهي التي نطق عنها قمه المناخ
فيما بعد وبالتالي الاولاد سيلفا وتعلمينا
ال ال ما احاطه من انتخابات وبالتالي هي
اول زياره له هناك ايضا اول زياره لرئيس
وزراء بريطانيا همم ستكون غدا هنا في شرم
الشيخ
اول زياره ايضا رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا ستكون
غدا همم من اللافت وصول ابيه احمد رئيس
وزراء اثيوبيا منذ قليل الى شرم الشيخ همم
همم
لم يعني بحسب المصادر هناك محاولات لوجود
عقد لقاء ثنائي ولكن لم يتاكد حتى الان
هناك تحديات كبيره جدا
ازمه المياه ااا مصر بتواجه ازمه من
المياه وتعلمين كما جاء ايضا في يعني كثير
من الاحاديث ازمه سد النهضه كيف سيتم
طيب ليس فقط قمه المناخ ولكن
هناك مشكله في
الوصول الصوره والصوت من شرم الشيخ مراسله
العربيه رنده ابو العزم شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المشاركه
الى ملف الاحتجاجات في ايران حيث اطلقت
قوات الامن الايرانيه الرصاص الحي على
مظاهره في مدينه مروان بمحافظه كردستان
ايران اشار موقع ايران انترناشونال عبر
تويتر
احتجاجا على مقتل سيده في عقاب تعرضها
للضرب بالهروات على يد القوات الامن
الايرانيه اثناء تواجدها في طهران
[موسيقى]
باربي باربي
هذا وبعدها مرور اكثر من 50 يوما على
اندلاع الاحتجاجات اعلنت نظمته حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه اعلنت ان عدد القتلى
ارتفع الى ما يزيد عن 300 شخص من بينهم 24
امراه
واحده وواحد واربعون طفلا وذلك فتنت 22
محافظه ايرانيه افادت منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه ان معظم القتلى نظيرها في
الحكومه الايرانيه مع المحتاجين كانوا من
محافظات الوجهستان ومازن تران وطهران
وكردستان وكيله
هذا وقد قال رئيس البرلمان الايراني محمد
باقر قالب قال ان الاحداث الاخيره التي
شهدتها البلاد اظهرت ان وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه والمساد الاسرائيلي لا
يبحثان عن تحقيق مطالب المحتاجين بل يسعى
ياني لصنع داعش جديد من خلال تحويل
الاحتجاج الى اعمال شغب وجريمه
[تصفيق]
الى اليمن الان حيث استبعد رئيس الوزراء
اليمني معين عبد الملك تحقيق السلام طبعا
بسبب اسرار ايران بحسب تعبير على سلوكها
العدواني
والالتزازي عبر ادواتها المتمثله في جماعه
الحوثي عبد الملك وصف المعركه ضد الحوثيين
بانها مصيريه و وجوديه ولا مجال فيها الا
للانتصار واكد ان الحكومه تضعوا في اولى
اولوياتها دعم هذه المعركه حتى استكمال
انهاء الانقلاب واستعاده الدوله
الخمسه ولكن بعد قليل
عمران خان يرحب بعرض الحكومه تشكيله لجنه
للتحقيق بمحاوله اغتياله ويعلن استئناف
مسيره انصاره نحو اسلام اباد
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه في ملف
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونجرس
الامريكي اصبحت ولايه بنسلفانيا في قلب
المشهد السياسي هذا الاسبوع حيث يتوجه
اليها رؤساء امريكا في الماضي وايضا
الحاضر الديمقراطيون والجمهوريون سارعوا
لتعبئه الناخبين قبيل انتخابات التجديد
النصفي ذهب الفريقان الى حد دعوه الرئيسين
السابقين دونالد ترامب اوباما بالاضافه
الى الرئيس الحالي لزياره الولايه حيث
ظهر الرؤساء الثلاثه في تجمعات انتخابيه
الرئيس الامريكي خلال تجمع للحزب
الديمقراطي ان انتخابات الولايه النصفيه
الاسبوع المقبل ستكون لحظه فارقه في مصير
الديمقراطيه قائلا انه يجب ان يتحدث
الجميع بصوت واحد من جنبه يدعى الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الى حشد
موجه حمراء عملاقه طبعا هنا في اشاره الى
لون حزبه من اجل ضمان الفوز على
الديمقراطيين لوقف تدمير البلاد وانقاذ
الحلم الامريكي حسب قوله
المزيد معنا من واشنطن مراسل العربيه
بيرغانم اهلا بك ببير الى اين وصلت هذه
الانتخابات وطبيعه المرحله التي وصلنا
اليها من خلال المنافسه
ان هذه المنافسه شديده وان الانتصار فيها
سوف يكون بالنقاط وليس من خلال موجع عاديه
يجتاح فيها الجمهوريون الديمقراطيين او
العكس حتى الان كل علم مؤشرات تشير الى ان
هناك عدد ضئيل جدا من الدوائر الانتخابيه
على مستوى مجلس النواب والمنافسه فيها
شديده جدا وليس من الواضح في اي اتجاه سوف
تسير جماهير الناخبين الامريكيين قال
الديمقراطيون لديهم حظ جيد جدا
للاحتفاظ بمجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ وكذلك
بنسبه لجوريين من سيقرر نتيجه هذه
الاتهابات هو المسود في يوم الانتخابات اي
يوم الثلاثاء
الان في اخر لحظات
اولا هناك رغبه عامه عند الامريكيين بان
لا تكون هناك سيطره من حزب واحد على البيت
الابيض وعلى الكونجرس الامريكي وبالتالي
هذه الانتخابات هي الانتخابات ضد
الديمقراطين ولكن ليس هناك حماس بالمقابل
من قبل المؤيديه الجمهوريين وخصوصا من قبل
المستقلين لموجه جمهوريه في هذا الوقت
لذلك هناك تقارب شديد جدا بين الطرفين
ويعمل الديمقراطيون بشكل شديد للاحتفاظ
باكثريتهم كما يعمل ايضا الجمهوريون خصوصا
الرئيس السابق ضلال ترامب لخلع هذه
الاكثريه من الكونغرس الامريكي
غياب الديمقراطيه اذا ما صح التعبير الى
اي احد هو مؤثر وعلى ماذا يعتمد بهذا
الاطار
هناك طبعا الكثير من التهويل في كلام
الرئيس بيده لقد شهدنا من قبل رئاسات
جمهوريه وديمقراطيه يكون فيها المجلس كان
النواب او الشيوخ مسيطر عليه من قبل الحزب
المعارض ولا تنتهي الدنيا السياسيه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عند ذلك ولكن
ربما يكون الرئيس بين يحذر بشكل خاص من ان
هناك عدد جيد من المرشحين الجمهوريين
المؤيدين للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب وهم
يرفضون نتائج الانتخابات السابقه وربما
يرفضون ايضا القواعد الديمقراطيه
والانتخابيه هذه المراه
داخل بحث او يمكن ان نقول انه همم
اوكرانيا ربما وعلاقه ترامب من جهه
بالرئيس الروسي وعوده انه لو كان موجود لا
ما انتهت الحرب هل مثل هذه التصريحات اي
تاثيرات على همم الشارع الامريكي او لا
الموضوع الداخلي بحث الان
الموضوع الداخلي بحث لو نظرت الى لائحه
الاولويات بالنسبه
الاقتصادي ثانيا تجدين حقوق النساء خصوصا
حقوق النساء في التقرير بموضوع الاجهاض
وهذه الامور مهمه جدا بالنسبه للامريكيين
ويكاد يكون الشان الدفاعي والعسكري
والعلاقات الخارجيه غائبا عن الخيرات
الاوليه الناخب الامريكي
[موسيقى]
ايه ده انت زعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب قبل اكثر من
عام ونصف طبعا احذيه خلافات دفينا بين
الجانبين حيث يقتنب اي فرصه للنيل من شخص
السيناتور ومن عائلته كذلك ساخرا من
قدراته السياسيه على ايصال الحزب الجمهوري
لاي فوز بالاغلبيه
علاقه بارده تجمع الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب بزعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه في
مجلس الشيوخ متشمكونال تشعلها ملاسمه لا
تنتهي وان كانت حده لهجتها اخف من ناحيه
السيناتور
منذ كان رئيسنا واتهامه مرارا بالفشل في
تمرير اجندته التشريعيه لكن الفجوه تتسعت
بعد خساره ترامب للانتخابات عام 2020 وقت
الحمل انصاره للكونغرس
لتبدا المعركه بانتقادات لشخص مكونال
ومكانته الوظيفيه فترامب اكد عجز الحزب
الجمهوري عن كسب الاحترام او الفوز مجددا
بقياده السياسيين مثل ماكونال العابث وفق
تعبيره محملا اياه مسؤوليه فقدان الاغلبيه
بمجلس الشيوخ
[موسيقى]
دعوه ترامب شبه المتواصله لاستبدال ما
كانل كزعيم للجمهوريين يدعمها احيانا
بتغريدات ساخره على موقعه للتواصل
الاجتماعي تروسا ووصفت بالمحرضه على العنف
حين انتقد موافقه ماكونل على صفقه لتمويل
الحكومه مضيفا ان لديه رغبه في الموت
ولم تتوقف صاله الرئيس السابق وجولته
عندما كان لنفسه بل تخططه للاستخفاف
بزوجته المولوده بتعيبان ووصفها بالمحبه
للصين فصول المواجهه الثنائيه جاءت ضربتها
اكثر تحفظا من جانب ماكونال الذي التزم
الصمت تجاه التغريدات ووصف اداء ترامب
بالمجنونه ورغم ان مكانه لا اعتبر ترامب
مسؤولا عمليا واخلاقيا عن اثاره احداث
الكونجرس الا انه لم يصوت لاداته
ليش موقع
ين الذين يدعمهم ترامب بالانتخابات
النصفيه مؤكدا انهم سيزيدون صعوبه استعاده
السيطره على مجلس الشيوخ وتحقيقه انجازا
جديدا يتمثل بصاحب اطول فتره خدمه فيه
الجو بارد كاميرا
[موسيقى]
ما يقدر كويس
سوري
[موسيقى]
الخامسه الرياضي
شكرا لك ميسون اهلا بكم تغلب المنتخب
السعوديه على نظيره الايسلندي وديا بهدف
من دون مقابل في العاصمه الاماراتيه
ابوظبي ضمن معسكر الاعداديه لنهائيات كاس
العالم سجل الهدف اللاعب سعود عبد الحميد
خلال مجريات الشوط الاول من الوديه
الرابعه للمنتخب ضمن برنامج الاعداديه
ستلعب السعوديه ضمن المجموعه المنجليه
الثانيه مع الارجنتين والمكسيك وبولندا
استعاد ارسنال صداره الدوري الانجليزي من
مانشستر سيتي
رفع ارسنال رصيده الى اربع وثلاثين نقطه
متقدمه بفارق نقطهتين عن مانشستر سيتي في
حين بقيت تشيلسي السابعه ويعالج الشمس في
الدوري المحلي حيث لم يفوز في اخر اربع
مباريات له
سيغيب الفرنسي كريم بنزيما مهاجم ريال
مدريد مره جديده عن صفوف فريقه ضد رايو
فايكانو غدا في ختام المرحله الثالثه عشر
من الدوري الاسباني كما اعلن مدربه
الايطالي
لا يزال بنزيما يشعر بعدم الارتياح بعد
اصابته قبل اسبوعين من انطلاق المونديال
اصبح يوسف موكوكو اصغر لاعب يسجل 10 اهداف
في الدوري الالماني بعد ما قاد دورتموند
الفوز على ضيف بخون بثلاثه اهداف نظيفه
افتتح صاحب 17 عاما
التسجيل لاصحاب الارض في الدقيقه الثامنه
في الدقيقه الثانيه عشر ليعود بعدها من
كوكو ويفسجل هدفه الشخصيه الثاني والثالث
لفريق قبل نهايه الشوط الاول ويصبح اصغر
لاعب يسجل 10 اهداف في الدوري الالماني
ولم تتغير النتيجه في الشوط الثاني
25 نقطه
على رصيده السابق بواقع سبع نقاط
على برلين بثلاثه اهداف لهدفين ضمن
منافسات الجوله الثالثه عشر ايضا من
الدوري الالماني افتتح جمال موسيقى على
التسجيل الضيوف في الدقيقه الثانيه عشر
واضاف اريك ماكسيما تشرب موتنك هدفين خلال
الدقيقتين السابعه والثلاثين والثامنه
والثلاثين ليتقدم بايرن ميونخ بثلاثه
اهداف في دقيقه ال 40 قلصا دودي لقب كيو
الفارقه لصالح الاعتبانين ومن ضربه جزاء
نفذها دافيد جاء هدف التقدم الثاني لاصحاب
الارض قبل نهايه الشوط الاول ولم يشهد
الشوط الثاني المزيد من الاهداف لتتهم
مباراه الفوز بايرن ميونخ التي ارتفع
رصيده الى ثمان وعشرين مقابل رصيد
من جهه اخرى اعلن اخبار
سديفز لن يشارك في مباراه فريقه المقبلتين
اثر تعرضه للاصابه واوضح النادي البريه ان
اللاعب لا يواجه خطر الغياب عن نهائيات
كاس العالم
ويعد دايويس لاعبا اساسيا في منتخب كندا
المشارك في المونديال لاول مره منذ عام
سته وثمانون
تتجه الانظار اليوم الى الياستوديوم الذي
يستضيف دور بايطاليا التاريخي بين يوفنتوس
وضيفه انتر ميلان يوفنتوس يدخل اللقاء بعد
تحقيق الفوز في اخر ثلاث مباريات للدوري
ويسع لمصالحته جماهيره بعد توديع دوري
الابطال وعلى جانب الاخر هل انت لدور
السته عشر من البطوله وفي هذا باخر اربع
مباريات له بالدوري
انت شاب
ولابرتيتا لما يمثله ديربي ايطاليا وما
يعنيه للجماهير الناديين واننا نوجه خصمنا
يتحسن باستمرار مثل انتر هذا يوفنتوس ب 40
من اخر ست مباريات في الدوري الايطالي
25 مباراه متبقيه وستكون امامنا استراحه
كاس العالم لذلك ما زال لدينا الفريق طويل
لنقطعه حتى نهايه الموسم الايطالي ستكون
مهمه جدا بالنسبه لكل الفريقين وهذا
امرؤكد بالنسبه للاعبيننا لوكاكو فقد
شعوره بالام قريبه من مكان العمليه سيجري
بعض الاختبارات الاسبوع المقبل قلت من قبل
انه سيعود في اخر مباراه لنا قبل انطلاق
كاس العالم ولكن للاسف لا اعتقد ان هذا
سيكون ممكنا انا حزين من اجله فقد عمل بكل
جدا طيله 60 يوما كي يكون جاهزه لمساعدتنا
في اخر مبارياتنا قبل انطلاق المونديال
ولكنه غير متاح حاليا
لمباراه ديربي العاصمه بين روما وضيفه
لاتسيو حيث لا يفصل بينهما سوى نقطه واحده
يحتل روما المركز الرابع ب 25 نقطه مقابل
424 لجاره
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لمتابعتكم اعود
اليك ميسون تفضلي
[موسيقى]
شكرا لليان بعد نجاته من محاوله اغتيال
يوم الخميس الماضي ابدى رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني السابق عمران خان ابدا ترحيبه
بعرض الحكومه تشكيل لجنه قضائيه للتحقيق
في الهجوم الذي تعرض له ومن جهه اخرى ذكر
عمران خان ان مسيره انصاره باتجاه العاصمه
اسلام اباد للمطالبه باجراء انتخابات
مبكره والتي تعطلت جراء الهجوم ستستانا في
يوم الثلاثاء لكنه لن ينضم لها شخصيا حتى
يتعافى من اصابته
في العراق اعلن مجلس النواب تاجيل القراءه
الاولى لمشروع قانون خدمه العلم طبعا
التجنيد الالزامي وذلك الى الجلسه المقبله
يذكر ان هذا المشروع والذي قدمته لجنه
الامن والدفاع النيابيه واجه موجه
انتقادات شعبيه واعلاميه واسعه رافضه
لاعاده العمل بقانون التجنيد الانسان
جدد رئيس مجلس اسياد السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان في كلمه له بقاعده حطاب العسكريه
الشماليه الخرطوم جدد نفي هنيه الجيش دعم
اي جهه سياسيه وحظ المؤتمر الوطني على
الانسحاب من المشهد السياسي
الوطن
القوات المسلحه دي لا مؤتمر وطني لا حركه
اسلاميه لحزب شيوعي لعيون ما عنده فيها
كلام ولا عنده فيها شيء ولا تتبعه ولا
تحرر ولا حتى
الكلام ده بنقوله لانه الناس بيقولوا
الجيش
اعمل مؤتمر الوطني
خلوا الناس يشوفوا في البلد
اكد على التلفزيون الرسمي في تنزانيا
مصرعه ثلاثه اشخاص في حادث سقوط طائره
تابعه لشركه ريسجن اير في بحيره فيكتوريا
لدى اقترابها من مطار بكوبا وبحسب تقارير
تنزانيه تم انقاذه 26 شخصا على الاقل حتى
الان من اجماليه 43 شخص كانوا علمتني
اياها نشرت التقارير صورا للطائره شبه
غارقه وهي في البحيره مع استمرار عمليات
الانقاذ
الى الصومال الان حيث قالت وكاله الانباء
الرسميه ان 21 من عناصر حركه الشباب قتلوا
اصيب 10 اخرون في عمليه عسكريه جنوب
الصومال لم تعطي الوكاله على الفور المزيد
من التفاصيل بشان العمليه العسكريه التي
جرت في منطقه جالكا سالمو في اشبيليه
السفلي بجنوب البيئه
[موسيقى]